[Music]
so for a long time I've been trying to
figure out how I can incorporate what
I'm doing in my life with filmmaking
into my youtube channel to share that
side of my life with you guys my
endeavors things I'm trying to do the
goals I'm trying to reach I've been
trying to find a way to best incorporate
that and I feel like if I had a segment
that was all about my filmmaking journey
since I was a kid until today the things
that I'm accomplishing some of my ideas
the things I'm excited about behind the
scenes footage I would love to share all
of that with you and I've been very
candid about the fact that film
criticism has never been my goal in life
filmmaking was always and still is my
goal that's what gives me the most
inspiration talking about movies online
is just fun you know it's something I
enjoy doing
don't worry not closing my channel down
not changing anything gonna still talk
about movies this segment is just gonna
be a bonus it's gonna be something that
allows me to share a lot with you guys
and open up a little bit so as most of
you know I got really interested in film
when I was 14 movies like Spider Man
Minority Report signs these films really
inspired me to look at filmmaking
differently and I begged my mom for a
camcorder I was like can you please can
I please please please have a camcorder
and eventually I was able to get a very
cheap one and I was like well is it I've
got it all
I have everything I would ever need to
make films that look as good as those
bills
I was very naive obviously I was very
naive and there were things about
filmmaking that I just didn't understand
and even today there's so much that I
have yet to learn and I can't wait to
learn it but back then I was just so
excited at the prospect of taking this
this cheap little camcorder and making
feature films that were of the quality
that I was seeing in theaters and I
spent most of my teenage years trying to
do that
hundreds of short films you know I've
talked about a lot of them here on my
channel by - Indiana Jones fan films one
of them just about an hour long almost
feature-length with in its own right and
two amateur features which I have also
discussed on this channel
you know these were never released
anywhere these were just shown to my
family and friends pre-youtube that was
my audience my friends and family once
they saw it that was it we worked for
months and months on some random project
while still going to school and having
normal jobs and then we showed it to a
few people we knew and that was it move
on to the next thing there was no way to
share it beyond that back then and so I
was always trying to work towards what
my audience which was just my family and
friends wanted trying to please them
trying to give them an experience with
our limited resources despite how
amateur and how quite terrible those
movies were it was a learning experience
I needed to have I needed to understand
what it felt like to make a movie with
nothing quite literally nothing just
your friends and a camera so obviously
once YouTube rolled around I got really
excited about the idea of having an
outlet to express myself artistically
and naturally what I gravitated to was
movies so my first channel was all about
film and it still is mostly all about
film because that's just what makes me
excited movies making them and talking
about them but like I said filmmaking
has always been my number one I love
talking about movies and I'm never gonna
not like that but making them is a
different experience man it's like
connecting with artists creating
something from scratch meeting people
who understand how important it is to
you you know crafting something that may
or may not be good it doesn't matter
okay the Internet and honestly I'm a
part of this I am a definite part of
this but the Internet takes so much
focus on whether or not what you created
is a masterpiece and it might not be and
more than likely it isn't but you still
got together and you made something and
that's just insanely inspiring to me and
to so many other artists out there and
that's one of the things I want to share
with you guys in this segment I want to
take you guys through my journey so
let's talk a little bit about auditorium
six auditorium six has not yet been
publicly released in regards to like a
VOD release or distribution but it
played it mini festivals I got a lot of
feedback but that experience was
eye-opening for so many reasons because
it was my first time working with a real
professional crew including actors and
background stuff we had about 15 people
that came together to make that movie
which was super amazing my buddy Matt I
mean he worked his ass off to build a
backstory for his character he had a
full binder filled with ideas about his
character and how he was raised
things he had experienced he crafted
even a playlist for his character
Katelyn E newberry great actress here in
ohio that I met on that project and she
was super inspiring she was just so
ready so planned so super professional
she had ideas and she just came to play
and everybody worked together so well
the most stressful element of making
Auditorium six was time because we had a
very limited amount of time we could
have this theater there were like five
or six days we had and we only had to
shoot at night and we had to wait for
all the customers to leave gratefully
the movie took place at night so that
helped but we couldn't start shooting
Wow there were customers still there so
we had to wait for them all to leave and
then we were able to set everything up
and we had to then take everything down
and disassemble everything at the end of
the day just to reset it up the next
morning so that took a lot of time time
was really the most stressful thing
there is we didn't want to lose the
location because we don't finish the
movie it's not like we can rebuild a
theater that looks exactly like that so
that was definitely the most stressful
thing but also super super helpful to me
as a director because I was able to
figure out how to plan things better how
to budget things better there's a
paperwork element to filmmaking that a
lot of people just they don't want to
talk about but unfortunately it's there
there's a legal side to filmmaking in a
paperwork side to filmmaking that isn't
fun at all it's not inspiring it's just
a boring boring thing but it has to be
done so you can make your movie and now
in the case of you know gigantic films
that are being made out there most
directors don't have to worry about that
but us small-timers
you know us people who save money to
make films or don't have any money to
make films and are trying to prove
ourselves as artists we have to do a lot
of
ourselves it's interesting as a
no-budget filmmaker or somebody who's
working with a low budget like for
instance auditorium six was by no means
no budget I spent a while and I saved a
lot of money to make that movie we at
the end of the day we spent seventeen
thousand dollars on that film completely
out the door and now this includes the
catering you know food transportation
lodging for the people who were coming
from far away to shoot this movie
because we did have a crew come from
Chicago to shoot this movie all of this
kind of stuff you know like we we have
to make sure that everybody gets paid
and that includes everything it includes
everybody's day rates because I wanted
to make sure everybody got paid as well
and that experience was just wonderful
being behind a red camera and shooting a
scene and then standing next to the DP
and shooting a scene with him and
working with the actors and it was just
it was life-altering now something I
mentioned on Twitter was that I had
something I was working on with
auditorium six because I was gonna
release it to VOD by now but I got an
email I got an email and I won't mention
who it is it's a small company you
wouldn't even know who they are they're
kind of they're kind of new but this
company contacted me and they said look
we heard that auditorium six did our
write at festivals and we'd like to see
it this was because it was nominated for
Best Short at the indie horror film fest
in Chicago which I was really flattered
by because of that nomination they then
asked if they could have a private
screener link for it and I was like of
course yeah so they watched it and they
got back to me and they were like look
we're working on something right now and
we really like what you did with it and
we want to know what your thoughts are
on it I don't want to like just say it
yet because I have signed the contract
and so have they but I haven't gotten
like 100% approval to announce it
basically essentially auditorium six as
a short is going to have a route for
distribution soon and that is just like
I I am so excited
that doesn't happen shorts don't get
distributed
they just don't that's really good for
us for our team for everyone who worked
on that movie that's really good for
Ohio as well
a short film shot in Ohio to get
distribution in some way that's really
good for us and I hope that it helps
Ohio filmmakers cuz there are a lot of
great folks out here it's nothing
humongous don't go don't get blown high
proportions not like 20 Century Fox or
so it's a short film okay it's a
low-budget short but it's it's the best
option we have at our disposal right now
as a small production company dark
forest Pictures and as a small filmmaker
from Ohio that's it's the best option I
have so I'm really excited to share that
with you guys when I have more
information but after that I really
wanted to make something different I
wanted to make something a little more
contained and a little more personal so
I started working on a script called
notes from Melanie which is about a
writer who's very successful monetarily
he makes money doing what he wants to do
which is right he's made tons of movies
and they've all got distribution and
he's in demand he's a fast writer and
people liked working with him but all of
his movies are not good and he works for
a studio called blood and jugs Pictures
FEA they specifically make movies that
are terrible they make the giant
tarantula in New York versus the super
duper octopus movies okay these are the
types of films he writes and he makes a
ton of money doing it and he's able to
support himself writing and he gets
constant gigs but he feels unfulfilled
as an artist because what he's doing has
no artistic merit and so he decides he
would like to write his first ever
serious drama script and he does and he
invites his very successful former
colleague Melanie to give him feedback
on his first serious scripts and she
arrives at his office which is where our
short begins everything else I said his
backstory and she's there to really just
tear into this script and let him know
how shitty it is we see clips from films
he's worked on before which were a blast
to recreate by the way so much fun to
recreate I shot this movie with Mason
Haider who is an incredible talent he
was so prepared holy I mean this
guy look out for him he is so so good I
mean he actually he's already been in
some great projects
he's incredible he is so so good Katelyn
Inu berry from auditorium six also work
with me again on this and she was just
as prepared to let you know how prepared
and how impressive these actors were we
shot a full rehearsal one take in my
phone 18 minutes long
no mistakes were made they were like
Broadway theater ready they were just so
on we use an office and we shot that
film over two days the movie sequences
that are included from his past films we
shot those throughout the summer at
different times and again just like
auditorium six it was such a wonderful
moment to be there and to just watch
these insanely creative talented people
working on this project and it just
meant so much to me to be involved with
it
and I can't wait to share it with you
and people who can see it at festivals
this year it's about to have its
premiere March first Friday at the short
sweet Film Festival in Cleveland it's a
local filmmakers night all Ohio films so
I'm really really excited to be there
and to support Ohio filmmakers because
people out here are trying and I'm I'm
just glad to be involved but with both
auditorium 6 and notes from Melanie
probably my favorite part was the score
sitting down with the composer and
working out that score now I am blessed
Aaron Jay Morton has been my composer
for both auditorium 6 and 4 notes from
Melanie he also composed the intro music
that you hear in every one of my videos
it was originally a GarageBand loop and
he contacted me and he said yo man like
yeah your intro yeah it's so we
took that original loop and he made a
more fleshed-out version of it and
that's what you've been hearing now for
a couple years so when auditorium 6 came
around I contacted him and I was like
look man like you're interested in
scoring for movies right you're like
yeah so we've developed a great
relationship since then and I can
honestly say I think this guy is a
musical genius Aaron J Morton as far as
I'm concerned as a musical prodigy he
can play just about every musical
instrument we'll be skyping together
because he lives in Tulsa
Oklahoma will be skyping together about
ideas for for music and he'll just like
he'll grab like a banjo or something and
just say what about this but I'm like
what like where'd that come from he'll
he'll just like he'll he's usually in
like an office wheel wheelie chair he'll
just wheel over to the keyboard and
start pumping out this thing and I to me
it's like what any director who's ever
had the opportunity to work with John
Williams must have felt
[Music]
and I told him I was like look man if I
ever have the opportunity to work on a
big film that I really want to make and
the studio lets me pick my composer
it's you like it is Aaron J Martin
without a doubt the guy is unappreciated
and undiscovered talent as far as I'm
concerned and I'm just so lucky to know
him and I can't wait to share some of
his work with you guys I'm just happy to
be involved in film and I really want to
let you guys in on that I want you to
know that I'm doing more in my life than
just going to screenings and talking
about movies I'm trying to write I'm
trying to get movies made I am getting
movies made I'm really working hard to
get this stuff done I was super
fortunate to land a meeting with the
president of the Cleveland Film
Commission and I went into his office
and after we talked for awhile he looked
at me and he said look man you're
exactly where you want to be you are
exactly exactly where you need to be but
you need to learn how to play the game
as I mentioned earlier there's a
paperwork side to filmmaking a legal
side to filmmaking I've got to learn how
to handle myself in pitch meetings how
to go about the proper way of pitching
scripts you know you don't just cold
call someone and say hey I have this
idea there you go let's get it made that
Studios very rarely ever accept
unsolicited material because then
there's this whole legal ramification
that comes into what if you are already
making something that's kind of like
that and that person Sue's you it's just
a lot of you know corporate stuff but
it's stuff that a filmmaker needs to
know and so that's right now what I'm
working on trying to really know as much
about talking to entertainment lawyers
talking to studios talking to firms
figuring out how all of that actually
works how projects get off the ground
it's not just having a great idea where
you can be inside some computerized
world and know about kung-fu like the
Wachowski x' came up with it's about
knowing how to go about actually getting
that project financed and off the ground
you know you can learn everything you
can about making a great movie and you
can maybe have it all in your head
but there's a lot of things that have to
follow
perfect place before you can get to that
point where you're even rolling camera
that's what I'm focusing on learning the
most about right now and I think that's
really been helping me a lot I've had a
lot of amazing conversations with some
great people over the past few weeks so
in the future I really want to share
this with you guys more I want to let
you guys in on this I'm very excited to
talk more about what's going on with
auditorium six once I have the full
go-ahead to do that I'm super excited
for some of you guys to see notes from
Melanie at any festivals this year it's
a film that's very personal to me it's
something I've kind of want to say about
the film industry and about how things
are made and it's it's more from the
perspective of someone on the outside
you know unless from someone on the
inside even though the writer has had
successful films monetarily it's it's
more from the perspective of somebody
who hasn't been given that opportunity
and maybe doesn't yet understand how to
achieve it and he's reaching for it so
it's a movie that I relate to and it's
it's one that I'm excited to share with
you really the best way I can describe
notes from Melanie is that it's two
characters that are warring sides of my
own brain you have one person who is
insane who just wants to throw
everything at the screen and then you
have another person who's like whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa pump the brakes buddy
let's make some good here and it's
really just kind of like two very
different contrasting writers having an
argument about how to make something
better and I think a lot of writers have
those two personalities in their heads
anyway I've said this before and I'm
just going to repeat it if I ever am not
able to always review films full time
like if for instance I'm getting the
opportunity to full-time direct a
feature that I want to make I'm not
gonna close my channel down sure I'm not
going to be able to review every film
and see every screening I'll take my
camera to set I'll make production
journals on set I'll share with you guys
people I'm working with I'll let you in
filmmaking is something I'm never going
to stop talking about it's so important
to me and when people come up to me and
say that in some way the stuff I'm doing
on this channel has has helped them
achieve something or they're going to
film school or
or anything like that to me that's the
world you know that is the absolute
that's the paramount right there for me
of just pure inspiration so I must say
thank you to so many of you who have
expressed things like that to me over
the years it genuinely touches my heart
as cheesy as that sounds it's
true so I have to be Who I am and I'm
inspired by that so thank you very much
so I'm excited to share a lot of this
with you guys I'm gonna give you behind
the scenes footage you know backstory on
what I'm working on ideas concepts just
things I want to make things I am making
at the time whatever it is I want to let
you in on it so guys thank you so much
as always for watching and please please
please keep writing and keep filming
[Music]
you